doit vraiment on va faire une interview
première fois
valeria bruni tedeschi votre premier
péché oulala je vais y arriver
pourquoi il a tellement je me suis
toujours sentie coupable je sais pas en
fait de quoi
mais j'ai dû faire un péché dont je ne
me souviens pas c'est ce péché originel
wet est peut-être vous est jamais remise
du péché originel vous êtes tout le
temps sentiment d'être dans le thé chez
guy plus loin que je m'en souvienne est
là aussi
ouais vous dis je m'exile c'est pas bien
l'amanite et je vais vous êtes chez moi
de travailler la télévision qui permet
même quand c'est pas qu'on ne sait pas
apprécié ce vaccin sentiment vague
projet south comme ça depuis toujours ah
oui aussi à non c'est vrai j'ai une
espèce de culpabilité l'attend voilà
exactement
ouais non mais c'est vraiment et ça rend
pas heureux non mais alors je trouve ça
il s'en va c'est pour pallier vous êtes
entrain de sympathiser ça se passe bien
je vois bien je la bloque
un travail quoi il devrait y passer
ben si vous il faut vraiment s'en tira
grand grande grande nécessité pas qu'on
le fasse comme ça je crois qu'on le fait
que c'est bien de le faire quand qu'on
peut pas faire autrement
il paraît qu'après on s'accepte moi j'ai
pas tellement envie de m'accepter
non vous voulez être contre vous ouais
bon jour je n'accepterai j'aurais baissé
les bras non ah non je rattache mais on
commence quand tous acceptent d accepter
le monde
bah oui mais mais du coup il ya la place
pour pour regarder alors si on est tout
le temps en train de faire la guerre on
est occupé à faire la guerre vous
pourriez beaucoup moins portée va
derrière votre première idole c'est qui
peut-être annie cordy allez et la bonne
dynamique et c'est vrai votre premier
coup tout s'en souvenait de ça quand
même
ah ouais c'était qui passe très bien
oleg mystique raf à il était quoi est il
était italo russe et je savais pas ce
qui se passait et je crois que je suis
tombée amoureuse mais je savais pas ce
que c'est pour eux alors prenez coup de
foudre on a vu c'était oleg anissimov si
tu nous regardes oleg première fois pour
de vrai vous en souvenez qu'un garçon
pour nous vrai quoi devrais l'amour pour
de vrai qu à ses primes tu as été triste
ouais vous regardez pas la culpabiliser
encore sur la non mais c'est toujours
toujours un peu triste un peu gay en
même temps quand on avance dans la vie
on laisse un trou derrière c'est fini
c'est fini
une chose qui est finie c'est une vraie
nostalgie qu'il s'agit quoi moi aussi
ouais ya un sentiment terry qui
s'appelle le derrière pour effet dès
lors nécessaire je leur en laisse ou là
il ya un truc
laurent et août a eu raison de tenir
derrière il ya un truc en train de se
passer je crois qu'on est réellement en
train de sympathiser très fort loi tepa
teura la soeur battu voix
pour la première fois la première fois
qu'un garçon on m'avait dit c'est et
oleg menchikov la première fois avec une
fille valeria jamais la première fois à
3 à 4 mais je vais pas répondre des
choses comme ça on en était la première
fois 4 je sais pas moi tant d je suis
pas j'ai un boulot à faire à chaud je
suis ma vi de questions voilà je vais
pas sauter une non plus oui
attendez excusez-moi valeria notre ami
et puis c'est elie semoun et du buzz qui
sentent ensemble comment ça va j'entends
des filles rires qu'est ce qui à
l'homosexualité c'est quelque chose
qu'on n'a pas le droit de vous dire on
est des êtres humains comme tout le
monde c'est dur on s'aime et puis c'est
tout oui ça va bien toi qui aime bien
avoir des scoops bah voilà on est
ensemble voilà nous vous regarde sur
l'amour verbalement et puis on aime ça
et ta femme et le prend comme ans et lee
j'entends mal
non cela exige la avec valeria c'est
vrai alors on en est d'aléria première
rupture
gg l'est j'ai pleuré m'a quitté ah ouais
c'est lui qui vous a quitté vous avez
pleuré ça durait depuis quinze jours
première cuite
ah oui c'est quoi ce bain je m'en
souviens pas parce que notre famille a
fui dans ce débat première tentative de
suicide quoi ben ah bon
thierry denis venir ici pour elle c'est
une petite tentative de 6
me jean hugues anglade comme c'est bien
je pense que on a fait un petit bilan
d'interviews laurent ça s'est bien passé
franchement honnêtement mauvais débat
ouais mais moins de bêtises et idées des
petits moments de grâce
enfin grâce un grand mot mais n'inquiète
pas un montage on va couper tous les
moments de grâce mais c'est toi c'est
toi qui m'a tendu mais tu m'as pas mal
crispaient aussi bon ben ça va c'est
globalement positif là et maintenant si
on faisait le bilan avis bilan parce que
c'est bien joli mais est ce que ça
marche le fait de faire un bilan à ce
que les gens sont satisfaits alors c'est
quel est ton bilan du bilan moi je
suppose que tu vas garder ce petit grain
je pense que le bilan est bien moi je
suis très satisfait du bilan et tuées
mais le bilan d'une année riche qui rit
je peux dire mon truc là
vu le ton truc qu'on le connaisse elie
semoun ton truc
non
excuse moi et lui ouais c'est pas ça
c'est quand même ça fait trois fois que
j'étais dirait nietzsche et pawel à la
tête mais line en ce moment là il n'y
aura atteint mezine attention mettez
doigt comme ça mais l'inattention
vacances
pour moi
ouais si elie semoun
moi je vais te dire et lui et michelin
perd quand tu joues rondes comme ça sur
cette musique c'est l'entrée était un
peu pour rire ah ouais parce que j'adore
personnes annoncé le nom des gens sont
venus c'est vrai que pour une entrée
c'est moins forte que ces mots gibier
c'est une bonne chanson le ses fans
chanson d'entrée ouais ouais ouais
peut-être mais ça n'a pas empêché de
rentrer quand même vrai zapping bon là
on a écouté la chanson mais vous savez
qu'il ya un truc quand même c'est que
j'ai eu
rolando exige le clip
tout nouveau 1
et vous
non
je
depuis
non
rappelé
et ces bonhommes excès de son premier cd
label bout pour moi
on joue
voilà heavy semoun alors quand vous avez
décidé de faire se disent que tous vos
amis vos vos parents votre femme à tout
vent que vous a dit ne fais pas ce à
quoi tu vas être mais oui c'est vrai
qu'on m'a on m'a déconseillé de le faire
ouais et motivés ça m'a motivé et non
oui parce que c'est mais c'est pas
évident je m'en aperçois encore
maintenant de tu vois là j'ai
l'impression d'être multi cartes je veux
représenter un 10 qui peu après les
cassettes des petites annonces assez
c'est vrai que c'est bizarre et je crois
que j'espère que les gens vont pas être
trop déstabilisés mais je crois que je
vous en attendant les gens obtiennent le
quota égales ses avances c'est à dire je
crois qu'on en a trente mille ou 32 ans
battre comme ça et puis ensuite j'étais
allé faire l'appareil que vous un
courage absolument incroyable et est
allé faire la première partie de laurent
voulzy
ouais c'est pas évident parce que les
gens qui ont dit arriver sur scène
surtout quand on n'est pas chanteur
je crois que tu as compris un petit peu
le système lorsque j'ai pas envie que
les gens s'attendaient à rire non mais
c'est vrai est quand même intéressant
sachant bien qu'ils aient comme ça c'est
un peu spécial
je déconnais entre les chansons pour
essayer de 2 que que les gens me
retrouve dans skins cause dans ce qu'ils
connaissent deux mois mais mais dès que
je commence à chanter ça allait tout le
monde dormait je devrais pas dire ça
parce qu'il peut être du mal
non je me fais franchement c'est très
visuel est revenue bon alors vous disiez
elie semoun si ça marche pas j'en ferais
pas un deuxième alors qu'elle est levé
avec lé verdict bas n'ont pour l'instant
je ne pense pas faire un deuxième je
pense plutôt faire un nouveau spectacle
mais ouais j'ai beaucoup de bouche d'un
seul coup une rafale de uche noir ça va
vite alors que je regarde ton truc comme
un vrai qu'est-ce que moyennement
confiance bien alors c'est que la chaîne
france 2 a fait une étude ce sont les
invités de tokyo elie semoun et vous
êtes parmi les meilleurs invités de
tokyo les meilleurs clients comme on dit
vous êtes en tête vous savez ça
annonçait pas vous êtes emprunter le
show confondues en tête mais qu'il est
le meilleur client c'est les gens qui
disent ah ouais on leur a demandé -
jours pour vous quel est le meilleur qui
est le meilleur invités on joue à la
télé c'est sympa c'est pas les mecs qui
se foutent à poils qui montrent leur cul
ou qui cassent tout sur les plateaux le
meilleur s je comprends qu'on voit
souvent la télévision parce que
effectivement le meilleur ça va toi
sinon il fallait que je passe une
réplique qu'il fallait que je remercie
les gens question suivante
la barre d'outils classé deuxième des
premiers l'année dernière pierre arditi
les passer deuxième c'était normal
aurélie on va pas les faire passer le
test ont valu de 1000 cartes de bons
clients tout de suite allé en tête des
sondages
agile cartes de bons pieds voilà c'est
qu'avec cette carte
le sondage il aérienne non non c'est
ainsi qu'était longtemps que j'ai pas vu
l'émission donc je me suis fait avoir
c'est ça là je veux dire la vérité
toi tu ne t'y crois pas mais pierre
arditi il ya cru j'ai dit voilà pierre
arditi ni un sondage qui était par
france 2 sur les bons clients et options
et où vous êtes numéro un tout autre
chose et puis on aiderait à ghislain
super tirer quelque chose avec ses
cartes on dirait prénom benoît le flanc
à une ses moules à chaque émission vous
parlez de dieudonné vous souvenez c'est
incroyable ok je n'en est qu'à une
époque mais c'est vrai on parlait
toujours de dieudonné
je me souviens un jour je sortais des
chiraquiens à kinsale et où dylan
arrêtés et voilà donc on va retrouver
quand même j'ai donné 5000 toi faire une
interview déjà donné
alors elie semoun vous êtes dieudonné
oui je suis ça va du dos bah je dirait
'nul personnes de couleur on n'a pas non
merci je vais pas me lancer là dedans ce
que je vais avoir un procès je n'en suis
dieudonné donc je vois l'habitude et
avoir des procès ait lieu je suis
d'accord je donne est ce vous fait
bizarre vous voir sans la barbe à la
télé ouais mais j'ai fait ça parce que
actuellement je suis sur un tournage de
film donc c'est pour ça que
disons j'essaye de ressembler le plus
possible mon ancien collègue
elie semoun c'est pour ça donc je dois
interpréter le rôle d'un juif c'est pour
ça c'est parfait si non c'est président
c'est pas évident pour vous tous je me
suis entraîné chez ils ont acheté des
pièces de monnaie puis je me suis jeté
dessus de supporters dieudo vous avez
écouté l'album solo d'elie semoun a way
le rossignol le rossignol et chantant
ouais j'ai écouté ça non mais c'est bien
il a raison de faire ça parce que disons
semaine enregistrant un petit plus à sa
carrière quoi si je peux lui donner un
coup de pouce éventuellement le pousser
dans un précipice et la chine perrenoud
vous connaissez kevin à covina résidents
contente de tarte
est ce que vous écrivez le public sénat
bah non c'est à dire qu'en ce moment je
commence à devenir une femme je compte
mes poils de vue est ce qu'il pensait de
la visite vous dire carrière solo que
j'ai dit c'est mon niveau de la carrière
des on élit après pris une tangente qui
ne me ressemble pas circuit il est
vraiment dans le commercial
il fait des gros sel ils vont énormément
de cassettes alors que moi j'ai préféré
faire ça le contraire
est-ce que j'exagère parce que j'ai fait
le zénith il n'ya pas longtemps il y
avait du monde
d'ailleurs il ya mon copain guy bedos
qui est monté sur scène et qui a un
petit peu insulté sur scène devant des
gens qu'est-ce qui va djilali il est
rentré sur scène il a dit
enfin bon moi je suis pas responsable il
a dit oui il est en train de chanter
pis là il ya quelqu'un qui a violé dans
le public et puis la dure a dit don d'un
droit de se moquer des juifs sans être
antisémite cette heure donc guy bedos se
sait c'est mon ami guy vial lui réponde
la bombe
maintenant quand les réconcilier
dieudonné voulu passer des petits coups
de fil de temps en temps on s'appelle je
les appelais pour son anniversaire
je les appelais quand sa famille est
décédé
non on s'appelle non mais on s'aime
beaucoup hein y'a pas de soucis alors
dieudo à des petites vannes comme ça
mais abaissé celle amitié haine l'amour
n ai jamais pensé à faire un duo un truc
un peu de sketches mais non à une époque
sont maintenant je le sens pas je vais
peut-être me mettre avec un chinois
schwope
dieudo c'est vrai que je vais faire une
tournée en israël pour votre prochain
spectacle
je vais prendre un effet y aller en
casque et un casque à ce que le oui au
fait vous avez un petit mot à dire à
elie au câble regarder l'émission
giovanelli si tu regarde l'émission bien
tu le sais
pechstein bon bah c'est sûr on a eu des
rapports un petit peu conflictuelle mais
tu le sais toi et moi c'est pour
toujours
et un nouveau
t
et maintenant la cie font des must
lancement en france bonsoir
il
alors j'ai tous les deux à nouveau
réunis long pour les fameuses petites
annonces sixième volume
elie semoun annonce la suite avec vous
deux alors il ya un casting absolument
incroyable de guest-stars via arthur il
ya adriana karembeu axelle laffont dave
dany boon bernard montiel laurent voulzy
lorànt deutsch estelle lefébure et
julien clerc et on est loin des les
blondes à forte poitrine en main
d'oeuvre non mais c'est vrai il ya un
casting du diable ah non on va mieux il
ya surtout nous donne ouais hein
bien sûr tout nous deux oui c'est comme
jacques chirac toi je suis apte enrayée
je suis allé lui la bernadette wacheux
catherine barma belle cicatrice est bon
bien donc un casting du diable sur ce
truc
wen mais dans les autres casse est aussi
en plein de gens à cette fois il ya un
paquet de gens qui veulent tourner avec
nous c'est parce que c'est on se marre
bien sûr que l'autre s'est déguisé c'est
vrai que tous les copains ou non
toujours quand est ce que je fais un
truc c'est marrant de venir mettre une
moustache ou ou une perruque on est tous
des gamins dont qui viennent une robe
maintenant bien sûr bien sûr je suis
jean flanc g45 année je réside dans le
val de marne françois pagny opticien à
bagneux nous sommes à françois nous
sommes réunis par le même handicap qui
font soit tu tu t'es endormi bonjour je
suis jean flanc nous sommes réunis par
le même handicap l'endormi site aiguë
qui peut aussi provoquer des troubles de
mémoire
françois qui est endormi non pardon
christophe pendant ces jean-pierre
j'avais oublié à la voyez c'est terrible
or on
vous pouvez nous aider à combattre ce
terrible fléau en envoyant désolé je
suis en retard je m'étais pas réveillée
bonjour je suis jacques vignaud vous
pouvez envoyer vos dons à cette adresse
a grenoble bonjour merci au revoir au
revoir
sue premier apparemment bonjour je suis
jacques vignaud bonjour je m'appelle
marcus et j'ai douze ans c'est pas grave
merci bonjour je m'appelle gilles je
suis mi homme mi femme s'est pas dad
bonjour je m'appelle cécile une femme me
grizzly ça non plus c'est pas grave
bonjour je suis c'est pas grave au log
diplômé de ça va s'arranger théologie je
pratique que cette philosophie qui fait
que donc quelques situations qu'elle se
soit bien c'est pas grave bonjour je
suis bernard montiel et non là je peux
rien faire
si quest se moquer d'une personne parce
qu'elle est attirée sexuellement par une
autre ouais j'aime les hommes elle est
bonne celle ouais j'ai couilles de le
dire
et quand cheikh mon doudou est bon ce
pays câlins sous la couette on se la
joue roméo et juliette
on range ses tabous de merde en se
plaisant houle dans un pack à ce poste
est foutu je suis peiné mais je suis pas
une gonzesse le corps un mois je suis
motard quand il faut changer les 4 ou de
la kawa bas je remonterai les les
trousses d'un mât chemisette et puis je
me fous les mains dans le cambouis j ai
le premier quelque chose à dire il aura
à faire un régime
bonjour vous désirez briller en société
au bras des plus grandes de sort des
frontières actuelles et bien c'est
possible grâce à nos gens seront
meilleures chances de sosies de stars
d'autres sociétés cibles très bien on
commence la tentation chéri que c'était
bien un bon jour je suis marie christine
a dream gérard bien te présenter d'ibis
à bonjour julien présente
on ne présente plus tant que ses
influences sur la première chaîne
bonsoir et je me arthur watts c'est
c'est pas beau tout ça à mon fils c'est
impossible de présence
on a tous donc une petite fille et une
jupe ta gueule on dirait une chèvre
bonjour je m'appelle laurent voulzy face
à ça c'est bien sympathique les gens
sautaient de grandes agences sur des
sosies de stars encore t'es bon teint
sociaux mais il est où notre jean
croissance nationale 1 excusez moi
j'étais au gala mont pelé ouais là je
n'étais pas le radeau de la méduse ce
bateau c'est lui qui n'a fallu lui en
voudrait dire qu'on est trop fan finie
ça on a tous trop mignonne trop sympa un
peace hôtel que ma petite soeur ouais
finisseur nutella ton concept en acheter
un neuf scènes nom n'a pas envoyé c'est
moi tu le perds reçues on me désole
alors autant avrillé 1 par la poste
on voulait savoir si l'état par les
laisse son émission en plus ce serait
trop bien qu'ils viennent à la niche de
dania s'afficherait trop bien que sa
copine
des mots qui résonnent ya les filles
comme entité tête elle y annoncer moon
la suite
donc quand on voit les réactions du
public qui se dit on se passe de
commentaires alors qu'est-ce qu'il ya
une aire de malus en plus chaque fois
dans ce ballet danse mais lucien a
accusé jacques baillet le bêtisier qui
en ont marre ans il y a et puis il ya
toute la phase d'écriture de préparation
enfin tous les invités qui viennent et
c'est ça a été vachement bien monter
c'est le favori qui avait brisé
c'est drôle ce qui se passe dans le
désert en ce moment parce que par
exemple sur deux shows tv dès la 2 je
vous ai pas raconté au zénith
il ya un truc où on entend on entend les
techniciens qui parlent entre laissé
ouvert les micros les techniciens et on
voit comment les mecs qui balance sur
toi pendant ton spectacle de mayol et
ils me l'ont dit pendant toute la
tournée on se fout ta gueule tous les
soirs pendant que tu joues à bompas
qu'ils ont eu des petits casse comme on
les assistants ici ils se parlent entre
eux et mondiaux fait l'enregistrement va
te montrer j'ai trouvé ça vachement
drôle et je les vis dans le dvd dans le
bonus c'est assez créatifs les dvd en ce
moment ouais tout ce qu'on fout sur un
dvd en plus du spectacle parce que les
gens sont plus en plus exigeants il faut
il faut un beau truc là comme on appelle
ça c'est le machin télévision non les
mois comment réussissez non
comme on appelle ça les cocottes
cotisable sur un petit truc
j'étais plus la question d'un confrère
commandes des menus supérieur comme
quand tu te colle à la terre battue mais
le dvd
tu vois tu as un menu voilà le menu si
nous pensons que cela l'avait dit avant
serge petit replay serge lui plaît
comment les menus derrière nom du pr
maintenance et la banque ont maintenant
chelsea clairement que et chacun pour sa
gueule alors dans dans ce dvd de je vais
pas raconter au zénith
il ya des rappels attend là que les gens
comprennent là on parle pas du disque on
parle pas des petites annonces on parle
du délégué d'accor c'est drôle ce qui se
passe dans le dvd en ce moment parce que
par exemple sur ton spectacle sur le dvd
de son spectacle au zénith je vous ai
pas raconté il ya un moment tu laisses
les pistes des techniciens ouvert bon
alors ouais attend ce massif andin et
ceci quand robin thicke en grand bain je
leur fais virer quelqu'un très surpris
que vous me posiez cette question là
c'est marrant avec le dvd en ce moment
j'ai un peu pris au dépourvu que je suis
devenu voilà ça y est
tiago et quelle prise vous voulez qu'on
prenne au montage rien ou la deuxième
tout tout tout bacharach c'est le public
qui décide du montage bon pour mon
disent que c'est vrai que les gens
n'étaient pas d'accord au départ et que
je l'attends non non c il est plus
facile pour un chameau un oui il par le
chas d'une aiguille que pour un riche
d'entrer au royaume des cieux caisse cas
sur votre bonus avoue ya des scènes
coupées
ouais pas mal le prochain spectacle
c'est septembre 2004 au bataclan au
bataclan
elle vous avez déjà vous allez jouer oui
je sais même après où j'ai joué et
élevés dans le monde je suis même en
2010 vers votre vie calculée par an
comme un damné
je sais que oui on en 2008 2005 je
connais le jour où j'ai de la mort
lorsque je préfère en 2006 tu pourrais
toi non mais même si tu te fais écraser
dans la rue les jours après pour le
planning ça fout tout le monde dans la
mer un point là mais ça se réserver une
salle pour le bataclan temps je me suis
senti en 2006 toi pas du tout même un
oui mais tu m'étonnes toi toi ben on est
d'accord
ah bon 2005-2006 formule quand tu dis
comme si c'est toujours non mais dans
quinze ans je sais ce que je crois
attends tu sais pas ce que tu vas faire
dans 15 ans même si je sais se couche et
l'inattendu inattendue à belene attendu
c'est après le spectacle mon petit chéri
bon enfin non mais je sais on quand on
joue un spectacle on sait qu'on va faire
une tournée après alors après ski entre
les deux genres serre c'est donc le
spectacle est pas écrit mais tu sais
déjà qui va le faire au bataclan que tu
fais la suite j cl est pratiquement
écrit mais il y aura quoi dans le bonus
du prochain dvd alors dans le bonus du
prochain dvd
oui il a tapé on ira le prochain
spectacle d'après